Juan Pablo Escobar. Welcome to Scandinavia.
Thank you very much. It's a pleasure to be
[inaudible].
Your name? These days is Sabastian merkin. Uh, is,
is that because, uh, the Escobar name is too much.
It is because, uh, the airlines,
they didn't want to sell any plane tickets to travel and to
get away from violence. You know, we,
we stayed in Columbia for a year waiting for somebody to help us
after, after your father died,
after my father's dad and we as the bodycon the United
nations, and nobody wanted to help us.
So it was our last option if we wanted to stay alive.
So that was when you could leave the country with your mother and your family.
The next day we changed our names we could fly with without any
problems.
Um, we, we saw some pictures of your father. Uh,
um, if you were to estimate
how many murders is he directly or indirectly responsible for?
Well, there is not, uh, an official record of that,
but I believe that it is almost about 3000 people.
Um, and yet to you, he is a very different person. He's,
uh, your father and you knew him as a very different person.
The murder. I know, uh, both, uh,
I know both because I, he was my father, but also he was abandoned.
And when I was seven years old, he told me, look, I am a band-aid,
that's what I do for a living.
Before this, before you really knew who, what kind of father was he?
Well, he was, uh, as far back as he can remember. Well,
I remember him giving me a lot of love, uh, being, uh,
at home with me and my family. Uh, he was a very good man with me.
I receive a lot of love from him. That's what I remember.
I also remember when we went to see the poor villages
in Columbia and to help them.
And that's the father that I knew at the beginning, but of course,
he's now more remember, eh, thanks to his violence. Uh,
not for his good behavior at the week.
You're describing also as vain person.
Well, yes. Yeah, he really took care of his own hair and
he stayed in front of the mirror for too many hours just to
watch his States.
So he took like two hours for him and
to get ready in the morning anyway. Yeah. And I, I asked him, what,
what did he take you so long? And he told me, Oh,
you can go to the dentist. I can't.
You, you, you call him a bad loser too.
Well, he didn't want to lose. He was always cheating even to me or to my mom,
to everybody. He didn't want to lose at all when he played soccer,
uh, the game only end when he was winning. And that's it.
Um, w w what, if you play the board game or you had some.
Well, we, yeah, we used to play monopoly, monopoly, and, uh,
yes, he hide all the, the money and everything.
And even if he lose a lot, he was always winning. And I didn't know why,
but it was making a lot of, uh, he was cheating a lot. Yeah.
Yeah.
Th th growing up as, as, as you did,
as the son of one of the world's richest man, according to the Forbes list,
at least, well.
Nobody, I didn't saw anybody from Forbes in our family.
Don't get into our, our wallets. It's, uh,
there is a way to sell a lot of magazines.
It's still, he a very rich man. He.
Was a very rich man and I asked him how money, how much money do you have?
And, and he, he told me, I don't know,
I really don't want to count that.
How could you, uh,
how could you notice that he was rich? I mean, what would you, what level of,
or w were you a spoiled, spoiled child or did he.
Well, of course I receive a lot of, uh,
presence from him.
I have more than Teddy motorcycles and we have our own SU private
too. You have how many motorcycles? So more than 30,
more than 30 motorcycles. Yeah.
Yeah. That's as per child, if.
I have it, but he gave me a lot of love and education,
and he always was very near me at the time
when he came out.
Well, you had this, you had this famous mansion called, uh,
Hussey and Annapolis. Uh, and th this was really a big estate,
a big property.
Yeah.
We have our own airport and also more than 10 houses,
more than a hundred vehicles for us and for the guests.
And if you didn't find anything inside the Hacienda,
you just could ask, uh, the chopper to go and buy that. So.
And, and, and you had a zoo as well. Yeah.
Yes. Sue and, and a lot of themes more than 100,
more than 1000 animals from all over the world.
We have hippos Veda [inaudible].
Yes. So how did they get them? How, I mean, this is.
Uh, well, he just sends a lot of people around the world to buy them. And,
and I also went with him to some Seuss inside the United States to
buy some other animals. He paid $2 million for the elephants.
You were, uh, I mean,
you were also the son of a politician, not only a drug dealer,
but a politician as well. I mean, Pablo Escobar was, uh,
an ambitious politician. Well, yes. And, and he, he,
um, he got far, uh,
but at some point it was like the,
the political establishment in Colombia, uh, realized who he was,
what he did and rejected him. Well, my father fell.
Well, my father felt here humiliated.
And the first answer was he resigned publicly.
And after that, he ordered the killing of the minister of justice.
And that was the year 1984. Exactly.
And after that,
all the word began from the drug trafficking business against
Colombia, as a country, as their government, the authorities,
everything was scales.
So from, from that day on really became real.
Yeah. It really changed a Columbia's life, our family's life, everybody.
And you were, you were mostly on the run.
Since then, from like everybody. Yes.
Like I felt like I was abandoned because everybody was chasing
also me.
I saw the reward signs asking for me.
What, why, why did they chase you?
Well, at the time the police in Columbia didn't recognize us as
individuals. They thought we were the same.
They went out through his family as well after everybody. Yeah.
How, how did you, I mean, how did you react to this? Did you,
did you talk to your father about this? Did you try to change it?
Of course, I did that a lot of times when you were mostly yes.
Mostly when I was 11 years old in 1988,
there was a car bomb exploded in Metagene January 13
against our home.
It was thanks to the Cali cartel that boom seven,
700 kilos of dynamite, who is much older,
older glasses around one kilometer around the city.
Everything was the,
I remember the newspaper they call that Metagene woke up as
Beirut.
But the how, how did you survive that? If it was meant.
It is a miracle. I have the pictures. I don't know. I can understand how.
What happened? Did you wake up and Jew or, I mean.
What's the last part you see when you're going to sleep the ceiling? Now, when,
when, when I get up, I saw the sky, there was nothing left,
but we were there.
Do you remember the conversations you had with your father, where you tried to,
to, to reach him to change?
Of course. Well, when I saw the bumps in the news,
I told him, look, what's going on. You don't, you don't have to do this.
You should not do this. A lot of innocent people is dying.
And he told me, he answered me. Look, I didn't invent this.
They use this against my family, my beloved ones. And I asked,
I answered to him.
If anybody puts me a bomb that doesn't allow me to put
bombs to everybody, I don't believe in violence.
And that's maybe that's why he approached the government and try
to, you know,
when he's rendered to the cathedral prison,
it was a way of showing the family
a little bit of respect. So he wanted to make peace.
He wants to end violence in Colombia and he's rendered.
And my mother was doing the same thing was just challenging him and ask him
him. Why didn't he stop by?
Did he, how did he react when you challenged him?
Well, he was very respectful. I will, I may say, but.
So he didn't, it wasn't aggressive.
Or he, he was open to the conversation,
but he wasn't willing to change anything. You know,
the CIA was after him, the FBI,
everybody was after him and nobody could stop him. Neither do I,
as a 14 year old kid.
He volunteered for prison. As you mentioned,
a prison that he got to build himself.
Well, he's the first bandaid in human history that really,
and actually built his own prison. And he changed quite comfortable as well,
very comfortable. And then he ran away again. Yeah.
When the government ordered the two translated him to
another place and they, he get out of the prison.
He was the owner of the prison.
He was the,
the greatest producer of narcotics in the world at some point.
Well,
he's accused of being the owner of the 80% of the market
in the eighties.
Yeah. Okay. Okay.
Do you have any memories of the drugs in your family?
Did anyone in your family use drugs, as you remember?
Well,
I have an uncle who died because of drug abuse.
And we are very aware of that. And when I was eight years old,
my father talked to me about drugs.
He put all the drugs in front of me and he teach me
how to recognize every one of them.
He told me what happened if I use of every kind
of them. And he told me if you ever want to try you come.
And we will try together. After that,
I felt that there was a legalization for me. So I,
I didn't felt curious. And I never tried. So you never tried? No.
Until I was 28 years old, I tried marijuana. And that's it.
Did, did he try himself? Do you think he used it in that?
He told me that he tried all of them, but not heroin.
And he told me that he always liked
marijuana, but nothing more. He taught me,
he teach me that cocaine was a poison to sell and not
to take.
When you were 16, your father died.
Yes. And you, you were the last person to talk to him.
Uh, he called you up. Why do you think he called you?
Because he wanted to be found he was away of committing suicide
because my father.
Because the fact the family you were in hide, no, you were in yeah.
In hiding in an apartment. Right? Well.
We try to get out of the country.
We flew to Germany and the authorities there,
they make us against our wire wheel.
They make us return to Columbia. And after that,
my father understood that there was no will be never any
safe place for his family.
And he understood that either we are going to appear
as that, or he had to choose that. That's why he started calling.
He has his body guard near to him.
He always teach me not to use the telephone because he was death as
his own words, don't use telephone because his death,
that's why he started calling more than seven times.
And I'm star protecting him. I just hang up the phone because.
I knew it was tapped. I.
Of course. And we, uh,
we were forced to check into the
hotel who was owned by the Columbian army forces.
So it was very clear that everything was stopped,
that we have microphones all over the place.
And he was the most wanted man in the world.
And he really knew how to get out of the authorities
very easily. And that's why it was so hard to me to know, no,
we came that he was calling just to be traced and.
Killed. So what was this last conversation about?
Well, we were talking about, um,
an interview from a very well-known magazine in Columbia.
He wanted to give me the answers and I was explaining to him,
I know all the answers. We spoke a lot.
You don't have to stay in the phone because you know, what's going to happen.
And I hang up, but he was kept calling and calling and calling.
And that's why I understood that he was willing to
get killed.
You, uh, as you know,
the official version of what happened is that Pablo Escobar was shot
by the police while trying to escape.
Well, we have more than one official version. If you ask the North Americans,
they will tell you, we were the ones who killed powerless. Covar.
And if you ask the Colombian police, they will tell you,
we were the ones and you have your own opinion about this. I don't have opinion.
I have proofs.
I have evidence is different from opinions because I have
the recordings of my father.
He never talked too much in the telephone.
So that's the first proof he had.
Thought he knew how to commit suicide.
Yes,
because we didn't want it to be tortured by the police.
And this is why you think that he committed suicide himself.
He, uh,
he taught me because he told me not to fire in his mouth or
any of the part just in the right year.
And it was the same place where the bullet appear.
What, what have you learned yourself?
Well, I learned so much about violence that I became a man of peace,
you know, because I don't believe in violence. I know how it can,
you know, disappear a country, a whole country.
It can change culture. It can change people,
money doesn't buy you happiness or freedom, even worse.
My father's money at the end,
he was for the financing, his own debt. You know? So it was,
we were hungry. We were dying financing because when,
when my father died,
the cartels approach to us and they told us we are going
to recover all the money that we spent, uh,
killing your father for this last 10 years.
So we're going to take everything if you want to remember to say alive,
thank you. Take everything you have. I have, I don't. I just want to leave.
I don't want anything.
W after, after your father's death,
where are you seriously threatened? Did you feel like he was threatened?
You're welcome. My, my health worth $4 million.
I have to explain that nobody else's is paying that mad money now.
So nobody don't get very happy about that, because,
so that was the price of your head. Yeah. That was the price. $4 million.
Just poor being the son of Pablo Escobar.
Was that because people were afraid his enemies were afraid that you would
revenge.
Yeah. They were very afraid of that.
Palm Pablo today, you live in Argentina. Yes. Uh,
you escaped, uh, from, from, uh, Columbia, after your dead,
you live in Argentina. You're an architect. I know. Yes.
Also an industrial designer.
And you have a wife and a kid.
Four year old kid. Yes.
And, uh, your mother, she is also there. What,
why don't you return to Columbia now? It's been so many years.
Well,
I have to wait 14 years since my father's death to say
goodbye to him, because it's because of the threats. You know,
everybody was telling me if you ever came back, we will kill you.
So I had to say in Argentina, I don't have, uh,
the option of returning to Columbia. That's not an option for me.
Thank you so much for sharing your story with us tonight. Thanks. So you, um,
on top of [inaudible].